it's time for some classic whoo and I am
gonna be taking a look at a Seventh
Doctor adventure which I haven't done it
in a while and the last one I did was
time and the Rani so yeah so I was due
for a good one and out of the options
that I presented to my patreon
supporters they have selected for me
remembrance of the Daleks which honestly
might be shooting me in the foot for
down the line because this might be as
good as the Seventh Doctor gets this is
a phenomenal episode I really do love
this thing and watching it again like I
haven't seen it for a few years now and
like I feel like I've gotten better at
appreciating classic Who that I did in
terms of you know for the time because
generally like in the early days of my
starting to visit classic who unless the
writing was incredibly you know clever
and the acting was really good they
could lose me because of the wonky
effects and because of some of the the
other if he stuff going on which isn't
really the fault of the show a lot of
the time I will still call out classic
ooh when I think design decisions were
bad but I unless it's a total fail I
don't usually call out the like the
execution of effects and things like
that
but so now that I'm at a place where I
better appreciate that end of it I'd
like this thing all the more and
actually I can kind of appreciate how
big this story was like scale wise
because like the number of Daleks that
are on screen at the same time the fact
that they're rolling down the streets of
London the explosions like the number of
legitimate explosions in this you know
we have a landing shuttlecraft we got a
mothership
we got the Emperor Dalek like this this
is really
impressive production design especially
from the time they even got some CGI
stuff in there that looks pretty decent
especially for the 80s on a TV budget I
mean I it's still shot in the very you
know point-and-shoot very basic way that
TV was shot so maybe that part of why I
didn't appreciate that at the time
because you know I'm I'm young so my my
idea of what is a big you know big sort
of epic scope thing is largely informed
by more modern shooting sensibilities
but you know looking at it now oh yeah
some impressive stuff this was the the
first episode of first story for
Sylvester McCoy's second season so
season 25 of classic Doctor Who and you
can tell that between the previous
season and this one they had really put
a lot of thought into what they were
gonna do with the doctor because the
first season he's he's not quite fully
formed as a character and seems to be
largely informed by whatever is very
much not how how the character was when
Colin Baker played him so you know he's
much goofy or he's much friendlier he's
kind of clownish and a bit but here we
get what I think the Seventh Doctor is
remembered for being sort of the game
master being you know the guy who's
thinking several steps ahead the guy
who's got a bit of a vicious streak and
I calculated one because the doctor can
have a vicious streak but if you were to
compared to say Tennant and the Tenth
Doctor that was a case where the doctor
when angry could be vicious
in the moment could be vicious this is a
doctor who plans and has to plan for
like there's there's some extended plan
he does that pays off in some pretty
aggressive moves that I think other
doctors it wouldn't have made sense for
them you know did it would have been out
of character for them and some people
can argue that it's out of character for
the doctor but I do think it it goes
from a general
generation so that sense of being
calculating while still having a little
bit of fun a little bit of sense of
humor but that underlying nature of
always being scheming of really plotting
out what it is that he's gonna do not
just flying by the seat of his pants
which normally is a trait I kind of
liken the doctor but it's interesting
seeing this other angle on him and I
think McCoy plays it phenomenally also
we've got ace ace is the best
I mean ace is just awesome and she gets
away with traits that I can find
irritating and other companions because
of how young she is so like someone as
young as she is sort of not always
listening to the doctor or following you
know the things that he tells her to do
don't bother me the here the way they
bothered me with campaigns who are you
know supposed to be in their 20s that
that I'm a little bit more are you
kidding me her like with her whole
attitude and her you I'm like no no no I
buy it she didn't stay put when she was
told to and she went back for her for
her stereo of all things I mean like how
awesome is a swell name another
companion who beats the ever-loving crap
out of a Dalek with a bat oh it's
awesome it's so good and and she's
terrific like every step of the way and
I always love to rapport between them
that the doctor has this you know
wanting to sort of get her to think
things through a little bit more wanting
her to learn but also kind of be a
little bit condescending to her cuz he
can be like that and her wanting to
learn but also not wanting to be treated
the way he sometimes streets her and
there's pretty good supporting work here
as well I think you kind of feel the
absence of the Brigadier because we've
got you know this other military guy
that doctor actually calls the Brigadier
it was like we call attention to the
fact that we could add a better
character here under ideal circumstances
but there's also the the scientific head
she's quite she's quite good she's
interesting I like
how she stands up to the to the military
guy because this you know she's like you
know you weren't hired for you know this
and she's like I wasn't hired at all I
was drafted and I like that she bites
back at him somewhat actually she has a
really kind of a few interesting moments
with her sort of assistant for secretary
like to the point that I'm like are they
flirting and that could just be me
projecting but the those two women I'm
like I feel like there's a history here
but a guy I'm Jun intentional I'm sure
especially given the era that the thing
was made but like it's kind of nice when
I can read that stuff in and not feel
like I'm crowbar II and just looking at
it going yeah I could see that the
Daleks oak got so many Daleks and you
know they're great we we have the bear I
mean you know they give credit to series
one for it but he would get odd Dalek
floating going upstairs we've got it
here we've got the special weapons Dalek
which is really cool I do like if this
is one of my nitpicky things I do hate
the voice on the Emperor Dalek and I am
gonna be talking later plot stuff so I'm
gonna be getting into spoilers soon like
it's awesome if you haven't seen it it's
awesome go watch it okay now I'm good
now like I'm more openly talk spoiler
stuff i i i know part of the reason the
Emperor Dalek speaks the way he does is
to cover up the fact that it's Davros so
it doesn't just sound like him but it's
still really it's great like even by
Dalek voice standards it's great I think
it's because it's such a shout whereas
in my my good Dalek dialogue aside from
exterminate isn't actually shouted it's
said very harshly but it's not actually
shouted whereas the Emperor Dalek stuff
is I'm like oh god stop like another
nippy thing I guess related to that is I
do kind of question whether or not this
story needed Davros like I'm not sure
his presence adds much other than to
basically remind us that he's still
alive and that he's still out there like
it could have just been an emperor Dalek
and the story doesn't change really so
yeah and and again I appreciate the
face-off between you know the the
Seventh Doctor and Davros I'm not saying
that those aren't good scenes or good
moments I'm just not sure what having it
actually be Davros adds and one of the
things that I am kind of annoyed about
is is that ever since Genesis of the
Daleks
classic who basically every Dalek story
was also a Davros story and that I don't
think is necessary and that kind of like
just annoys me as a pattern that said I
do like that this kind of picks up on
the strands of you know the the
fractioning of the Daleks that was sort
of planted back in revelation of the
Daleks and and because that's always an
idea that I love and I especially think
that they kind of explain it really well
here where you know it's sort of laid
out well look they're all about purity
so when you get additional mutations in
a certain strain they're gonna consider
each other to be too different they're
not gonna get along so like when you're
that obsessed with being the perfect
thing you're gonna start to eat your own
when somebody is not what you say should
be perfect and that makes total sense
and I like I've always wanted the Daleks
civil war to be a thing that comes back
and is more has more presents cuz it
hasn't had a lot like outside of
Revelation and this which I think is a
shame because I think there's a ton of
stuff to be mined from that especially
since you know Daleks threatening
basically everything that isn't a Dalek
has kind of been done to death at this
point but so that's really cool to see
here we've got the we've got this I
guess he's a sergeant who is kind of
takes a shine to you and I like the way
that that is dealt with because he he is
so charming
and he doesn't do that immediate he'll
turn that as soon as it's revealed that
he has links to not great people that he
suddenly starts acting like a different
character he still be hate you so it's
not like a Hans and and frozen kind of
thing he's still behaving like the same
character and so it does make you go
like can he be redeemed and then by the
man like no I guess not because you know
initially he's like look I didn't know I
was working with the Daleks I thought it
was just working for this guy who was
being controlled by the Daleks and I
didn't know that and he makes that claim
but then he goes and sides with him even
after he knows that they are working for
the Daleks yeah like oh dang and and how
he's dealt with is done pretty well the
the little girl is an interesting idea
I'm not sure they milked as much of that
as could have been done I wonder in some
ways if she's like a precursor to like
sort of the the Dalek shells that we
start seeing an asylum of the Daleks I
don't know
and also I recently in my overdue Doctor
Who Ron I recently did did my recording
for school reunion and it's it's
interesting that like that picks up here
this idea that the creativity of youth
is important for sort of working around
problems in a creative way and the
Daleks especially need that because
they're so fixed into a locked-in
mindset that they all think the same way
that they can't come at problems more
creatively and which is something that's
come up before as well so that's a cool
thing to sort of see you know that's a
cool thread to get pulled on again I
mean just overall this thing just fires
on all cylinders like little tiny
nitpicks but this thing really does cook
it it moves well the characters are
great they got great moments the doctors
awesome ace is awesome the Daleks are
cool like the the overall plot and arc
of it is neat sort of calling back in
some ways to the first doctor and having
him you know go for the the hand of Oh
and like the little things like he gets
a blind priest to help him bury this
thing so that the priest doesn't knows
that the caskets floating on its own but
the priest also knows him and like knew
the doctor from before he's like your
voice has changed and there's like this
one odd little scene that like is it is
a actually a pretty nice scene which is
one that goes on in a cafe and it's sort
of the seventh doctor's it's a little
bit the equivalent of the fourth doctors
do I have the right moment in genesis of
the Daleks and the Seventh Doctor it's
funny because he presents the problem in
a much more roundabout fashion which is
probably why he kind of doesn't come to
the same conclusion that Tom Baker's
doctor did because he presents it
through them through this metaphor of
what if there was no sugar and you know
then you know no one would have to be a
cane cutter and the guy who's serving
him who was black and actually played by
Jeffrey the butler from Fresh Prince of
bel-air that's just cool you know says
well you know if there was no sugar I
wouldn't even be here not that I
wouldn't be alive but I wouldn't be in
this place because my grandfather
wouldn't have been or my
great-grandfather or whatever wouldn't
have been kidnaped
to be put into slavery to work in the
cane field I'd be an African right now
and it's it's an interesting way of sort
of coming at that conundrum that the
doctor has visited before but sort of
like coming at a different angle and
having a different input it makes sense
that this doctor kind of allows himself
to do what the fourth doctor wouldn't or
couldn't and without feeling like a
betrayal of the character because he
does pause and ruminate on it he does
sort of work the question over in his
head it's just until you get to the very
ends the story you might not realize
exactly what it was he was doing there
so yeah this is great I love this this
story probably I mean it's it's my
favorite seven doctor story that I have
seen because I have seen more than just
the ones I've
reviewed for this series so far it'll be
tough to topple III I hope to enjoy
other Seventh Doctor stories I would be
surprised if you know if anything was
better than this this is just great
remembrance of the Daleks have you seen
it do you have remembrance of it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of something
you do because there's buttons and links
set up there's a whole bunch of links in
a pl box and all sorts of stuff there's
a link to my patreon if you're feeling
generous if not you don't have to look
in the description or click on any of
that stuff if you don't want to because
at the end of the day folks you are the
council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]